I'm crying all day long
I will cry and cry and cry
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen I am the youngest
and fastest rising star in the history
of professional wrestling and I am here
to answer the internet
Who's hotter Arielle or Jasmine does
Arielle have legs yet
um yeah let's say human and but that
also means but what if I don't want her
to have legs
maybe maybe I want to be under the
[ __ ] sea
huh yeah
you know
would you rather be able to have sex
with any five people with any five
people for a year or get to powerbomb
whoever you want whenever you want for a
year I literally do the second one year
round so I guess the first part that was
pretty easy which celebrity would you
most want to see in a sex tape
woof
um see my brain immediately goes like to
a grotesque place because like I can
look at any woman naked if I want to now
God Adventure the internet so I think
I'd want to see like someone like gross
and fat I want to see Oprah [ __ ] that
would be rad so mjf wants to see Oprah
[ __ ]
please
if you were in an open field with an
aluminum aluminum baseball bat how many
10 year olds with bike helmets could you
take down before the dude an infinite
amount and my aim is so precise and
Immaculate would you do you think you
would uh at some point
like the the morality of just pummeling
kids with that oh no I'd be laughing the
whole way through would you give up an
inch of penis length for an inch of
height dude I could give up seven inches
and I'd still be [ __ ] packing heat so
yeah chop my dick off basically would
you rather have your porn search history
shared with your Twitter followers or
your parents dude post it on Twitter I
don't give a [ __ ] yeah I don't talk to
my parents they [ __ ] suck hate them
what's the important history like any
weird [ __ ] in there no just normal
classic like MILF
um stepsister [ __ ] like DP [ __ ] I'm a
man just normal [ __ ] that everybody else
looks up would you rather have sex with
two midgets or two seven foot tall girls
so this is an interesting this is
interesting I like my woman on the short
side but I don't want them that short
because I'm nervous it would go all the
way out the other way
so I'm going to go with the tall chicks
just so I don't murder anyone
yeah I mean I don't want to go to jail
for sex then I'd be like bring
because he's sleeping with little boys
what's the youngest age child that could
beat you up none any child in the world
like I never see those like kids in
Russia who were like fighting a [ __ ]
tree growing up did I [ __ ] those Russian
kids up and the bear I'm mjf come on
what is that
for a lesser man I'm sure they'd have a
better answer but would you rather date
a girl who constantly sneezes on you or
who constantly farts during sex sneeze
on me all day long the last thing I want
to do is just
don't like smelly sex if you're into
that cool dude weird [ __ ] Kink but
it's not my thing so yeah just sneeze on
me all day long as long as when I'm
[ __ ] you I don't have to like smell
like just gaseous fumes the entire time
if you can make your girlfriend's
breasts as large as you they already are
as large as you wanted they already are
but yours would be the same size how big
would you go we're fine I'm not changing
a thing all right say you're starting
from scratch with her starting from
scratch so she's she's a double d with
like the skinniest waist you've ever
seen
so I guess yeah I guess my tits I guess
I'd have to put up with it because I
just love slapping those [ __ ] things
around dude also it could it could be
cool in my profession like be the
wrestler with with huge tits could be as
it could be something there if you found
a porn online of your buddy and his
girlfriend would you watch it would you
say anything to him I'd watch it and I
would immediately tell him and I would
make him feel so bad about it I'd be
like you make weird faces your dick
looks weird like that would dude please
send me a video should you lock a dog
out of the room when you're having sex
okay so I have a cat
love my cat cat's name is Piper when
it's go time when it's time for the
fiance to hop on the maximum ride love
Piper to death Piper's going out the
door because it gets loud it gets sweaty
and it's not a safe environment for any
pet if you could pick one country to run
what would it be America 100 America one
day maybe you never know
mjf
well good point
um good point I'm not even gonna deny
that my mama gonna deny that because
it's the truth we run the media thank
you would you rather prematurely come in
your pants before sex or start crying
midsex I'm crying all day long
I will cry and cry and cry because there
is nothing more see your response to me
makes me feel like you come way too fast
if you're because if you come fast that
thing that can and does happen to guys
crying maybe you no no no see I you seem
like a great guy
but it sounds to me like you have an
issue and it's not it's not an issue I
have nor is it one I ever want to have
so um
laughs
the devil goes in thank you all right
who is the hottest celebrity you'd have
a chance with if they got to know you
Sadie sink
there's something about Sadie sink and
maybe it's because I got like a redhead
thing but there is something and you
think if she met you that she'd be like
stranger things have happened
if you were taken hostage five years ago
what would surprise what would surprise
you most about the world today
the fact that Brandon Walker has a
podcast and is making money great
[ __ ] answer you know I'm not even
kidding you that's a great [ __ ]
answer if you saw it five years ago
you'd be like this [ __ ] guy this
Bumpkin from the sticks I can't believe
he has a job
if you're watching on YouTube click here
to subscribe so you get all the new
episodes as they come out and John what
should they click if they want
notifications revolver make sure you
click thumbs up for the like hit that
Bell icon